what I want to do in this video is think
about what it means to have an opposite
of a number so let me draw a number line
here so let's draw a number line now
let's put some numbers on this number
line so we can start at 0 and if we go
to the right we have positive numbers 1
2 3 4 5 as we go to the left we get more
and more negative so negative 1 negative
2 negative 3 negative 4 and I could keep
going on and on and on so let's pick one
of these numbers let's say that we pick
the number 3 what is going to be the
opposite of the number 3 well the
opposite of the number is a number
that's the same distance from 0 but on
the other side so 3 is 3 to the right of
0 1 2 3 so its opposite is going to be 3
to the left of 0 1 2 3 so the opposite
of 3 is negative 3
let me make a little table here so if we
have the number the number and then we
have its opposite we have its opposite
so we just figured out that if you have
the number 3
its opposite is going to be negative 3
now what if your number is negative what
if your number let's say the number
negative 4 what's the opposite of that
and I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think about it on your own
well you say okay negative 4 is right
over here
that's negative 4 it is 4 to the left of
0 1 2 3 4 to the left of 0 so its
opposite is going to be 4 to the right
of it so 1 2 3 4 it's going to be
positive it's going to be positive 4 and
so you're probably starting to see a
pattern here the opposite of a number is
going to be the opposite sign of that
number if you had
if you have a positive three here its
opposite is going to be negative three
if you start with negative four its
opposite is going to be positive four so
one way to think about it it's going to
it's going to have the same absolute
value but have a different sign or
another way to think about it is however
if this is three to the right of zero
its opposites going to be three to the
left of zero or if the number is four to
the left of zero its opposite is going
to be four to the right of zero so let's
do one last one what is the opposite of
what's going to be the opposite of of
one well one is one to the right of zero
so its opposite is going to be one to
the left of zero or negative one or
another way to think about it one is
positive so it's opposite is we're going
to change the sign instead of being
positive it's going to be negative it's
going to be negative one either way that
you could think about it